إلى أوكرانيا حيث وقعت سلسلة من
الانفجارات بالقرب من قاعدة عسكرية روسية
في شبه جزيرة القرم الآن يظهر مقطع فيديو من
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي أعمدة من الدخان تتصاعد
في الهواء يقول المسؤولون هناك إن خمسة أشخاص
أصيبوا وإجلاء العشرات
من منازلهم على
الرغم من أن وسائل الإعلام الرسمية الروسية تقول  وزارة الدفاع
الروسية تلقي باللوم على التفجير في
ذخيرة الطيران المتفجرة التي نريد
إحضار ديفيد ماكنزي هنا الذي
يتابع جميع التطورات الأخيرة
من keeve ، أعني مربكًا للغاية هنا
خاصة بعد أن حصلنا على هذا البيان
من الوزارة الروسية ، ما
الذي تعرفه أكثر
أننا نعرف القليل جدًا  إلا أنك شاهدت
مقاطع الفيديو الدرامية تلك التي التقطها أشخاص في
مكان الحادث وشاركوها على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
لأعمدة الدخان هذه تتصاعد فوق
ذلك الجزء من
شبه جزيرة القرم الغربية الروسية المحتلة من قاعدة جوية روسية وفقًا
لإعلام الدولة الذين كانوا يتناثرون
من كراسي الشاطئ في بعض الحالات
ووفقًا لبيانات الصحة ، أصيب خمسة أشخاص على الأقل
بجروح  حاولوا هناك من هذه الانفجارات ،
قاموا بإجلاء عشرات الأشخاص
من الجوار المباشر
كما تقول
وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الروسية تقول أن هذا كان من
ذخيرة
انفجرت في القاعدة الجوية قالوا إنه
لم يكن هناك أي ضرر لأي أصول
في المطار  أو الأفراد هناك وحتى
الآن لم يعلق الجانب الأوكراني من هذا الصراع
على الإطلاق
على هذا ،
لكن الصور الدرامية جدًا القادمة من
شبه جزيرة القرم
في سيفرسك يتم دفن المدنيين حيث
لا يوجد أي وقت آمن بالنسبة للمقبرة لا ترسل
أي قنبلة كبيرة جدًا لا  البناء في هذه
المدينة الواقعة شرق أوكرانيا على ما يبدو خارج
قائمة أهداف روسيا في دفعهم البطيء ولكن الذي
لا هوادة فيه غربًا ،
تقع هذه المدينة على هامش ما
تسيطر عليه الحكومة الأوكرانية ، وهي
محاطة من جانبين بالقوات الروسية
في الشرق وإلى الشمال
على بعد خمسة أميال تقريبًا  قصف على بعد ثمانية أو عشرة
كيلومترات هنا
خطر دائم
بين الأنقاض التي يعيشها الناس
2000 من 11000 قبل الحرب
يبدو أن التشبث بفاليريا بالكاد لا يبدو كذلك  الجليد
قذيفة أخرى تنفجر
مدى صعوبة العيش هنا الآن ،
أنا لا أدرك ذلك لكنها على وشك أن
تعلمني مدى
صعوبة عدم مزاحها ، فهي تعود مع
منشار ولوح أرضي يتم تنظيفه من
مبنى في مهب كل يوم كل يوم
كل يوم مثل  حسنًا ، هذا صعب ،
لماذا نعم عضلات جيدة ،
لماذا تبقى هنا إذا كان من الصعب جدًا أن
تبقى
درس فاليريا بالنسبة لي ، نعم الحياة هنا
صعبة للغاية ولكن هذا هو المنزل والمغادرة
سيكون أصعب
بيتي نعم بيتي
ولكن  إنه أمر خطير للغاية هناك
قنابل وانفجارات ويجب
أن يبقى أحدهم تقول إننا نذهب
إلى الطابق السفلي عندما يكون هناك قصف
حسنًا ، أنا قادم إنها تقودنا إلى
الطابق السفلي ،
لذا أنت نائم هنا أنت تعيش
هنا  تنام هنا منذ أكثر
من ثلاثة أشهر ، تقول
هنا في الأسفل لقد ذهب
بريقها المبهج ، ليس لدينا غاز وكهرباء ومياه أو اتصالات تقول إنه ليس لدي مكان أذهب إليه هناك المزيد تريد أن ترينا ، نعم ، انظروا إلى جيران فاليريا المحطمين  مثل طهيها
بالخارج ،
مرحبًا ، لقد أحضرتني إلى ما تبقى من
منزل صديقتها ، لقد دمر جميع
الأشخاص الذين كانوا هنا ، هل نجوا ،
لقد أنقذهم الله ، كما تقول ، لكنهم الآن غادروا
وفقًا للمعايير المحلية ، قصف هذا اليوم
أقل من المعتاد
هذه السيدة المسنة
تغامر بالخروج من أجل
الطعام تخبرنا أن توزيع الطعام الذي تحتاجه
لم يصل بعد أن اقتربنا
ولم نكن محظوظين جدًا لأولئك الذين تركناهم وراء
نيك روبرتسون cnn siversk أوكرانيا
أنت